قال القائد العام للحرس الثوري الايراني
اللواء حسين سلامه ان الدول الغربيه تنفذ
سياسه الضغوط القصوى على بلاده وتستخدم
ادواتها كافه ضد الشعب الايراني الدول
الاوروبيه باستضافه الجماعات الارهابيه
لبلاده محذرا من نفادي صبر بلاده تجاه تلك
الممارسات
شوارع الدول الاوروبيه اصبحت ساحه حرب ضد
ايران مارسنا ضبط النفس امام هذه التحركات
وصممنا مدى صواريخنا بطريقه حتى لا تشعر
الدول الاوروبيه باي تهديد الدول
الاوروبيه تنقل النفط من الخليج الفارسي
ونحن نضمن النقد الامن لهذا النفط لم
نستخدم اي من ادواتنا ضد هذه الدول وفي
المقابل الدول الاوروبيه تمارس سياسه
الضغوط القصوى علينا الدول الاوروبيه
تستضيف القنوات المعاديه لنا بشكل رسمي
وتزود الجماعات الانفصاليه بالسلاح
وتستضيف الجماعات الارهابيه نؤكد لهذه
الدول ان عليها ان تكون حذره وان لا تعرض
نفسها للخطر لان الصبر الايراني له حدود